vibrations abusive pollution de l'air et
visuel sur tourisme
le conseiller jean rousseau ne mâche pas
ses mots pour parler des autobus
touristiques d'un vieux québec
depuis 1998 le nombre d'autobus qui
envahissent son arrondissement n'a cessé
d'augmenter selon lui ce qui est
désagréable c'est que c'est le bruit
c'est la pollution ce sont les
vibrations
c'est aussi l'image que l'on laisse les
touristes une peau voire des autobus
non il vient de voir le monument de
champlain selon la ville de québec plus
de 30000 autocar par année se promène
dans le quartier touristique de québec
résidents du québec depuis une vingtaine
d'années michel maes a été témoin du
phénomène nous ce qu'on souhaiterait ces
cas une réflexion pas de panique et pas
de partir en peur on utilise foyers du
québec sont content de trouver ce beau
show du doubs c'est de s'assurer que moi
regarder on est rendu à un certain point
le tourisme en demandent toujours
comment on peut être sûr et cet
équilibre là le nombre d'autobus
touristique est toutefois loin
d'inquiéter les hôteliers de québec
selon lui ils sont indispensables au
maintien de la clientèle
particulièrement les aînés lorsqu'on a
des personnes plus âgées ou que c'est
difficile à marcher malheureusement mon
trottoir
les rues sont parfaites en conséquence
et on a besoin de rentrer en véhicule en
ville avec les valises avec tous au csc
propre à nous aussi notre ville c'est
que les autocars représente 40 % de
l'achalandage des hôtels selon
l'association hôtelière de la région de
québec pour certains citoyens le nombre
d'autobus est plutôt un beau problème
c'est bien pour l'économie de québec qui
fixait une ville touristique ça fait
comme ressortir aussi un cachet qu'on
voit en angleterre touristique héros
ça te promener les touristes moscou
c'est bien la ville de québec à une
réglementation qui encadre les activités
des transporteurs notamment en
interdisant plusieurs secteurs au cours
des prochains mois conseil municipal se
penchera d'ailleurs sur cette question
du nombre élevé d'autobus du québec ici
félix morissette beau lurette au canada
québec